mein name ist wolfgang luttenberger
privatiers der dienstgrad ich bin
kommandant des kommandos
luftunterstützung und einer der ersten
drei piloten die auf diese modernen
hubschrauber der hier hinter mir zu
sehen ist agustawestland 169 m
ausgebildet wurde ein hubschrauber der
dem österreichischen bundesheer neue
fronten eröffnet topmodern am beginn
seiner lebensdauer steht und derzeit das
beste in seiner gewichtsklasse in europa
darstellt wir hatten eine sehr fordernde
ausbildung zweieinhalb monate haben wir
in italien verbracht wir werden noch bei
diesem hubschrauber weiter ausgebildet
gemeinsam mit italienischen armee und
ich freue mich wenn sie die gelegenheit
nutzen und sich diesen hubschrauber
sowohl fliegend wie ekstatisch bei der
airpower hier in zeltweg in der
steiermark am freitag und am samstag
persönlich ansehen